Russia's economy is highly dependent on
raw materials exports but the country
can't offload all its massive reserves
of oil and gas on the EU and equipment
such as pumps and machinery can't be
replaced or repaired that's because you
sanctions prevent Western engineering
companies from dealing with Russia those
sanctions don't only involve energy
sector trade restrictions they also
forbid trade and items which have a
potential military use so-called dual
use items such as engines and pumps and
a raft of Russian foreign bank accounts
have also been frozen
besides that foreign investors and
moneyed Russians have also taken 90
billion euros out of the country a
punishing capital outflow that sent the
ruble plummeting the central bank's 36
billion euro intervention to prop the
currency up was to no avail the ruble
has now lost 27% of its value against
the euro since the beginning of the
Ukraine crisis consumer prices have shot
up by an average 19% and the country's
gross domestic product has fallen by 3.2
percent
but Europe is also straining under the
sanctions a recent Austrian survey
showed that some two million jumps are
threatened by the sanctions and put the
financial damage at around 100 billion
euros